what is your prediction for the 2020
election
uh i every day i wake up and i change my
mind
what's today then today is friday the
16th of october 2020.
what's your prediction yes so yesterday
i thought biden
today i think trump is going to win but
it's going to be close and it's going to
get very messy
take me through the thinking
okay so national polling uh and i i
invite people
they is how soon after we record this is
this going out
less than a week so pretty quick okay so
i interviewed with a guy called jim
rickards who was one of the analysts who
predicted
trump's first election uh very early on
uh will be going out at some point in
the next week or two after this goes out
and uh we've had him on the show a
number of times
and what he was saying was yes that
biden is up in the national polls by 10
to 12 points
he is uh but national polls don't matter
because in america they don't have
national elections
right it's all done state by state so
you have to win
the battleground states uh the fact that
uh
biden and harris are gonna get let's say
four million more votes in california
than trump doesn't really matter because
you only win california
once so the national polling isn't
necessarily indicative of the result if
you remember in 2016
hillary won the popular vote by quite
some margin didn't really help her
because of the electoral college
so that's not well that's one part of it
obviously the shy trump voter
is a huge phenomenon right and also i
think
it's not been much covered in in the
mainstream media uh
in this country or much of the
mainstream media in america but what is
happening in many cities
or several cities in america now is
full-blown riots
burning down of property shops people
are being killed in the streets for
you know turning up to some protests and
being pro-trump literally being shot in
the head
etc etc and uh the antifa people who are
doing this are now taking that
fight to the suburbs they're taking it
into where
the middle class quote people live and
i can tell you one thing that i know
from experience
uh the moment you start messing with
people's sense of safety
the moment a middle-class couple with
two children and
nice car and a garage or whatever
suddenly feel like there's
armed people outside who may well burn
their house down
that is the moment when people will vote
for anyone
as long as they promise to prevent that
which is my greatest fear with all of
this
right and i don't know if you remember
when we had the blm riots in london
i had a massive super viral thread on
twitter talking about
this very thing that the greatest danger
of allowing these riots to happen and
then
being biased in terms of saying they're
largely peaceful when police officers
are being attacked etc
is that if you show people these scenes
of disorder long enough
and this you show the police backing
down and not tackling and not addressing
the sort of
disorder then what they will eventually
go is look
i don't care what this guy i don't care
if he's racist
i don't care if he wants to deport
immigrants i just care that he or she
is going to deliver stability and order
and my sense is that there will be many
people in america
who don't want to see their cities
burned down who are going to
look at what's happening and go look i
don't like donald trump
i think he may be a bit racist i think
he shouldn't talk about
women the way he talks i think he's
obnoxious i think he's brash but they're
gonna look at that and go
what what's the choice here i can either
have a racist sex as president
if that's how they see it or i can have
my house burned down now you put that in
front of any certain person
right that's that's what i see
so i i've sort of been disenthralled of
this idea that the national polls are
necessarily a strong predictor it's
going to be close
and it's probably going to end up uh not
being
uh a result on election night we may not
see a result
during which time donald trump is almost
certainly going to be
uh the leader because republicans tend
to vote in person democrats much more
uh with the voting uh do the voting via
post
so what you're gonna have is a week or
two when
donald trump quote unquote won but the
election result isn't unconfirmed and
then those ballots may come in
and he may then lose
man that's not a healthy situation my
friend
um i'm glad you know one of my biggest
criticisms of trump is that he refused
to say that he would hand over power
peacefully
uh until yesterday which is when he
finally did which i'm glad
uh because i think you know that's
completely unacceptable in a democracy
for one party to say they wouldn't
accept the result of an election
on the other hand it's equally deeply
unacceptable for biden to refuse to talk
about whether he's going to pack
the court or not because if you start
messing with the
supreme court and the number of justices
on that to suit your political agenda
well that's the end of the american
project as well
so both of those things are completely
unacceptable i'm glad trump has wrote
back on that i hope
biden uh and kamala harris now say
they're not gonna do that as well
because
uh that is very very important but it's
gonna get messy
it is douglas i asked douglas the same
question this has been a theme i asked
god sad i asked
andrew doyle i was talking about
yourself uh and
douglas gave the most he had to pull the
fence out of his ass
uh in order to be able to uh actually
speak but he said
um whatever happens it's not going to be
very well accepted and he's got some
quite big fears which is interesting
because he's now in america
like he's now over there so like fair
play mate
like if stuff gets set on fire you've
decided to pop yourself in amongst it
um yeah i agree i think that no matter
your political leaning
trying to undermine the democratic
process at large
really has to be one of those things
that's unacceptable it's like look
you can two foot slide tackle me i can
push you while you're off the ball
but no one can come in and pick it up
and run away or shoot the referee
like these things are outside the rules
of the game in fact they change the
rules of the game
if we're supposed to be playing chess
and you rugby tackle me to the floor
like that kind of just what would we
what are we doing here there has to be
some upper bound but again like what
have we been this
disintegrationist left as ben shapiro
and
dave rubin refer to it like
that game of one upsmanship
will do something will break some rules
so we'll break some rules so we'll break
some rules
and think as well everybody's
self-branding everyone looks
in some form or another for some reason
there is a particular
minority who look to political leaders
as uh examples as role models of how
they should
like you spend their lives morally or
just you know
trump says something then you get it
regurgitated or biden say something then
kamala harris says something they get
regurgitated
like if they are saying well we can
break all of the rules and they're
supposed to be these
paragons of diplomatic virtue right
they're supposed to be the ones who are
the least uh um at the mercy of trans
as you know the [ __ ] lighthouse in
the storm type [ __ ] that's what your
politicians are supposed to be
um if they're prepared to keep on
changing all of the rules
what precedent does that set for
everybody else and it really
it really can quite quickly become a
vicious cycle so yeah i think
um the next when is the is it the 22nd
of november when is it
the third of november oh [ __ ] it's very
soon
it's soon man wow so i mean the next
three weeks
going to be they're going to be
compelling well let me
forget compelling if you like horror
movies
there is another aspect to this and i
think you speak to that very well which
is that
if you allow politicians to to conduct
themselves in this way
and to delegitimize the democratic
process which both
sides have done uh but particularly in
my opinion the the democrats
uh in america and the left in this
country as well uh
then what you end up with is a situation
where we are now where 36
of both democrats and republicans feel
uh that violence is justified to achieve
your political ends
so a third of both supporter groups are
quite happy to use violence
right which has gone up from eight
percent about two years ago
so if you've got that situation the
election is in dispute both parties are
undermining
the the democratic process and
encouraging their followers
uh essentially to feel like violence is
a way of resolving this issue
not a good recipe not a good recipe